THE MIDDLE CLASS:
I’m sure you’ve heard about the
middle class shrinking. Growing wealth inequality,
housing unaffordability, less retirement savings,
inaccessible healthcare, and declining purchasing
power. These have become the hallmarks of the
rapidly disappearing middle class which has
shrunk over 10% within the past 50 years.
That might not sound like a big number but keep
in mind, that refers to over 30 million people.
Not to mention, many of the people who are still
part of the middle class are just scraping by. The
mainstream media frequently attributes this shift
to capitalism, billionaires, inflation, politics,
and greed. There's no arguing that these factors
have indeed played a role in the growing wealth
inequality, but what if I told you that there
was an X factor that no one ever talks about:
tech. Tech is often seen in the exact
opposite light as the great equalizer.
It’s what gives everyone access to the same
information, knowledge, and opportunities.
But rarely do people look at the other side
of this equation. Take a look at this graph
for example. It portrays the rise tech over the
past 50 years. Now, compare it to the graph about
the shrinking middle class. You’ll see that it’s
almost a perfect inverse relationship. Of course,
correlation does not imply causation but thinking
more about it, this would make a whole lot of
sense. On a macro scale, tech has made the global
economy far more competitive as far more people
are able to participate and compete. On
a micro scale, tech has made traditional
jobs like being a teacher, police officer,
and firefighter completely unviable as the
cost of living in many areas has adapted to
tech compensation. So, is this really just
a correlation or is tech the culprit that’s been
secretly destroying the middle class for decades?
THE SPECULATIVE ERA:
Taking a look back, the impact of tech on
economics can be traced all the way back to the
1950s. This was the beginning of modern tech as we
saw the formation of the silicon wafer industry.
At the time, the tech industry was really quite
a foreign topic to the general public. It was
just something that super smart researchers at
prestigious universities messed with, similar
to quantum computing today. There was really no
commercial applications for tech and as such,
there was really no money in tech either. It
was all funded by meager government grants and
university budgets. So, the industry was really
just filled with a bunch of people who were truly
passionate about tech but all of this would change
in 1957. 8 PhD graduates who were conducting
research under professor William Shockley would
take his research and start their own company:
Fairchild Semiconductor. This betrayal would
make way for the rise of the entire semiconductor
industry as it led to the creation of dozens
of tech companies including both Intel and AMD.
This made tech a relatively viable business by
the 1970s but it still didn’t have all that big
of an impact on the economy. Most people just
viewed it as a fad or as a niche industry. A
perfect example showcasing this mindset is Steve
Ballmer’s parents. If you’re not familiar with
Steve Ballmer, he was the former CEO of Microsoft
and is worth over $100 billion. But back in the
1970s when he told his parents that he was gonna
drop out of Stanford to join Bill Gates, his dad
said “What the heck is software?” and his mom
said “Why would a person ever need a computer?”
Let’s just say those statements aged really
well but you can’t even blame them as tech
was seen in the same light as crypto is today.
Some people swear by it claiming that it’s the
future of money, finance, and economic growth.
Most, however, wouldn’t put much more than 10
bucks in Bitcoin. But it wasn’t long until the
people who bet on tech early would start seeing
massive upside starting with Steve Jobs. In 1978
Steve Jobs would make his first million at age
23. Bill Gates would follow just a few years later
in 1981. But, while this was impressive, it didn’t
mean all that much. Virtually all of their net
worth was just on paper. This however would all
change on December 12, 1980. This was the day that
Apple went public giving Steve Jobs a net worth of
$217 million. This too was completely on paper
but as a public company, the legitimacy of his
wealth and tech wealth in general skyrocketed.
6 years later, Bill Gates would take it the
next level with his own IPO that gave him a net
worth of $350 million. Just one year after this,
Bill Gates would not just become a billionaire but
the world’s youngest billionaire. It was official,
you could make serious money off of tech but
tech was still very much a niche portion of the
economy. It was something that young nerds who
have nothing to lose like Bill or Steve messed
with. Everyone else though had real jobs if you
know what I mean. Fortunately for them, ignoring
tech didn’t really affect them all that much but
this would slowly start to change with the 1990s.
THE OPPORTUNITY ERA:
The 1990s was characterized by an explosion in
the number of tech companies. The general public
still hadn’t bought into tech but investors had.
As such, anyone and everyone could get funding
to go try their luck at making it big in the tech
world. And many did, hundreds of successful tech
companies were started during this time period
propelling their founders into the billions. But
that’s not what we’re really concerned about.
We care more about the tech industry’s impact on
middle class and this was really the first middle
class generation that got involved in tech. In the
late 80s and early 90s, an unprecedented number of
people would start majoring in computer science.
Over 40,000 people were getting CS degrees every
single year creating a new sector of the middle
class. Things didn’t get too out of hand though.
While tech companies paid generously, in the
grand scheme of things, compensation was still
relatively modest. In 1995 for example, the
average Microsoft employee was making just
under $60k. For perspective, the median household
income in 1995 was $37,000. So tech households
were making about 50% more but nothing too crazy.
From time to time, you would hear about some tech
employee that’s a friend of a friend that become
a millionaire thanks to stock compensation. But
this was more of a gamble than anything especially
during the dotcom bubble when the vast majority
of internet companies went under. Speaking of the
dotcom bubble, the burst would completely destroy
the tech spirit. Annual CS grads would fall from
a peak of 60,000 per year back down to 40,000 as
people feared that tech was indeed just a fad. I
can imagine the old folks back in the day telling
their unemployed CS children that they told them
so. They should have just become an engineer or
a government employee. While they wouldn’t have
the same earnings potential, they would’ve had
far more stability and peace of mind. This was
the state of tech for much of the 2000s. While
there were a few startups here and there like
Google and Facebook that were making strides,
the big tech industry had fallen and it had
fallen hard. In fact, many of these tech giants
would never recover. Cisco for example, was at one
point the world’s largest company. But during the
dotcom crash, they would fall 80% which they
still haven’t recovered from. It was the same
thing with Intel and AT&T and Xerox and basically
every other big tech giant of the era. Microsoft
was the only giant that ended up recovering but
it took them 17 years and a fundamental shift to
do so. It seemed like the tech prognosis
was pretty clear. Tech was here to stay,
sure but it’s days of exponential growth were
over. Looking forward, it seemed like tech would
just become another established industry like
finance, healthcare, or education. People would of
course continue pursuing CS degrees but it wasn’t
in the hopes of becoming an overnight millionaire.
The perspective was much more pragmatic. Tech
simply paid more than most other industries and
these big giants like Cisco and Microsoft were
much more relaible than the startups of the 80s
and 90s. This created a new upper middle class,
the tech class that were just slightly more well
off than the middle class. This divide, however,
was about to grow to indescribable proportions.
LEFT BEHIND:
It’s no secret that tech compensation has
gone through the roof over the past 15 years.
Google’s median compensation currently stands at
$295,000. Comparing this to Microsoft’s average
compensation 30 years ago, we’re talking about
over a 5X difference. And this disparity becomes
even larger when we compare to household income
growth. Over the past 30 years, median household
income hasn’t even doubled while tech compensation
has over quintupled. But that’s not even that
accurate of a way to look at it because the
average household is just earning cash while tech
households are earning tech stock which over the
past 15 years has been 5 to 10 times more valuable
than cash. So a $300,000 compensation package
from Google is actually closer to earning $700 or
$800,000 in cash somewhere else. In other words,
back in the 1990s, tech people at the top
tech companies were earning 40-50% more than
the middle class. Today, tech people at the
top tech companies are earning 10 times more.
We should also mention that the term “top tech
people” encompasses far more people. Back in 1995,
Microsoft themselves only had 18,000 employees.
Today, Microsoft has 221,000, Google has 174,000,
Apple has 164,000, Meta has 71,000, and those
are just the mega tech companies. Zooming out,
we’re talking about tens of millions of people
who are earning leaps and bounds more than any
other profession. And I think this graph really
encapsulates exactly what I’m talking about. Tech
has objectively eclipsed every other sector
by nearly 10X and that was as of 2015. Also,
I’m not just talking about people who are directly
employed by these tech companies or even people
who are working in tech specifically. I’m talking
about people who leveraged tech vs people who
didn’t. Uber, just a regular old taxi company
but combined with the power of tech, they’re
worth nearly $100 billion. AirBnB, just a regular
old rental company but combined with the power of
tech, they’re worth over $80 billion. Similarly,
law firms are earning $90 million for just a few
months of work for a tech company. Teachers are
earning millions for teaching online instead of at
public schools. And the top influencers are worth
hundreds of millions if not billions. And those
are just a few examples. Tech has seeped into
every industry and sector you can think of and
the wealthiest people of any industry are the ones
leveraging and investing in tech. Everyone else is
unfortunately stuck at $40 to $60k jobs hoping
for a 3% raise every year. When tech was only 1
to 5% of the population, this wasn’t too big of
a deal. But as tech has grown to encompass 20,
30, 40% of the population and in some cities
even the majority, we have started to see a
massive wealth divide. And it’s not caused
by the top 1% or low taxes or capitalism
or any of that. It’s actually just caused by
our peers who made in tech. Let me explain.
THE
CONSEQUENCES:
It’s easy and quite popular to blame some sort
of elite class or Blackrock for the pains of the
majority but really that’s not the case. Jeff
Bezos spending $500 million on a yacht isn’t
causing your groceries and rent to skyrocket. Do
you know what it is though? The people around you.
When someone around you is willing to pay more
for groceries or houses or cars or whatever it be,
prices are naturally going to go up, and the best
example of this is Austin. Austin has always been
part of the tech scene as its home to Dell. But
over the past 10 years and especially during the
pandemic, every tech company you can think of has
expanded to Austin or has grown their presence in
Austin. I mean just take a look at the companies
with the largest office space in Austin. Number
1 is of course Dell, but then you have Apple,
Google, IBM, Oracle, Indeed, and Meta. As such,
Austin has seen an insane influx of high paid tech
workers from California and Seattle. Consequently,
the median price of houses has nearly tripled,
rent has gone up over 13% annually, groceries have
gone up 14% annually, and basically everything has
become far less affordable. I’ve lived in Austin
for nearly my whole life and over the past few
years I’ve seen countless neighborhoods pop up
where literally every single person works a remote
tech job and owns a Tesla. And I’m quite confident
that these people are the number 1 reason for
skyrocketing prices in such cities. This isn’t to
say that we should blame these people or that it’s
their fault by any means though. Like anyone else,
they’re just trying to create the best lives for
themselves. With that being said though, it’s very
important that we understand the modern economy
for what it is. It’s not a case of the top 1% vs
everyone else. It’s a case of people in tech and
it’s surrounding sectors vs people who are not.
The modern economy works for tech and it sucks for
everyone else. This has been a growing trend for
many decades but we’re currently at a extreme
crossroads where the options are basically to
join or die. And this makes sense because moving
forward, everything will be tech related and we’re
currently going through the painful transition to
where tech becomes the majority. So, in the end,
I don't think the current economic pain is due to
money printing or high inflation or bad politics
or any of that, though they all play a role for
sure. Rather, I believe the current economic pain
is a byproduct of the world economy evolving into
one where tech is not just a leading voice but the
dominant voice. If you’re already part of the tech
world, you’ll have a great time. If you’re not,
the future won’t be all that different from a
tech dystopia and that’s what’s really happening
to the middle class. Speaking of the modern tech
economy, a lot of people are worried that AI is
gonna take everyone’s jobs. Check out this
video to hear why that won’t be the case.